[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
el sahel esa vasta región subsahariana
que desde hace tiempo inquieta a la
comunidad internacional por la
propagación del terrorismo yihadista
para analizar lo que está pasando en el
sahel hoy nos acompañan en este estudio
beatriz de león como investigadora del
centro de seguridad internacional de la
universidad francisco de vitoria
bienvenido a beatriz muy buenos días
carlos robin guitar responsable de
influencia para áfrica occidental de la
organización oxfam bienvenido robyn hola
carlos y en dúplex françois xavier
freeland es periodista independiente fue
corresponsal en mali y además publicó en
2017 libro mal y más allá de la llegada
francesa bien bienvenido hola buenos
días
sage en una región crucial para la
seguridad global hoy en primera plana
[Música]
la amenaza yihadista en el sahel se
recrudece a pesar de todo el esfuerzo de
misiones civiles y militares de la unión
europea especialmente del rol de francia
realizado durante 8 años el terrorismo
yihadista sigue propagándose por esta
región pasando del norte de mali a la
zona llamada de las tres fronteras mali
burkina faso y níger extendiéndose
además a países costeros como costa del
marfil y ghana y todo esto mientras la
industria del secuestro florece en esta
región unas 3.000 personas han sido
raptadas en lo que va de año por grupos
armados y yihadistas prácticamente el
doble que en todo 2020 hoy analizamos la
realidad del sahel pero antes repasemos
algunas portadas diario libération lleva
preguntándose desde hace años ya como en
esta portada de 2019 sahel guerra hasta
cuando voice of america un titular muy
significativo ecos de lo sucedido en
afganistán para la misión de francia en
el sahel son comparables son comparables
ambas situaciones no lo preguntaremos en
el programa le figaro esta misma semana
titulaba como putin establece a sus
mercenarios en áfrica ligando esta
situación con la retirada francesa y ese
famoso grupo de mercenarios llamado
wagner implicado en numerosos conflictos
del que por cierto moscú niega una
conexión directa y el diario el país
esta semana publicaba un artículo bajo
el inquietante titular la industria del
secuestro florece en el sahel y en el
norte de nigeria bueno beatriz cuáles
son las claves que explican esta
preocupación por lo que está
aconteciendo en el sahel pues el sahel
son muchas crisis a la vez primero
tenemos una crisis de seguridad con
grupos yihadistas obligados al qaeda y
ligados al estado islámico con grupos
armados tenemos también una criminalidad
organizada y aparte de la crisis de
inseguridad tenemos una crisis de
gobernanza recordemos que malia hay un
golpe de estado dentro de un golpe de
estado pero también países vecinos como
game at están viviendo transiciones
tenemos evidentemente una crisis de
desarrollo la falta de trabajo para la
juventud y también bueno pues en casi 9
millones de personas en hambruna y una
pobreza extrema y bueno pues todas esas
crisis y por una última crisis que me
parece muy importante resaltar que esa
crisis de la cohesión social con las
milicias de autodefensa
la población local ya armada y matándose
entre ella con masacres a mujeres y a
niños en algunos sitios del sahel todo
esto conforma una situación en el sahel
bastante bastante compleja pero si
coincide la visión de robin de esta
situación de varias crisis yuxtapuestas
como nos describe a sí sí totalmente yo
creo que aquí que de construir un poco
el entender de la de la crisis de sahel
porque no es una crisis son varias
crisis están en una crisis humanitaria
ahora son más casi tres millones de
personas desplazadas en la región
teníamos una crisis que estaba enfocada
inicialmente en el malí y como usted lo
mencionó que ahora se está desplazando a
otros países de la región entonces ahora
mismo son 20 millones de personas en la
región que desean una existencia
humanitaria entonces la análisis que
nosotros tenemos en examen también es
que en los últimos años se ha enfocado
mucho en una respuesta militar que ha
sido un fracaso porque hoy en día la
estrategia en particular de francia y
del resto de la comunidad internacional
ha fracasado porque en la crisis que
estaba en el mar y ahora está en otros
países de la región está acercándonos
desde cada vez más también a la cuesta y
entonces hay que repensar ir a los
causales de los problemas y de las
crisis de sahel que sean también un tema
de gobernanza en temas de contrato
social en temas de desarrollo como la
dicho beatriz françois xavier frenan
nuestro compañero es periodista
independiente fue corresponsal en mali
además publicó como decíamos en 2017 el
libro mal y más allá del llegar françois
al presidente de macrón anunció este
verano que la presencia militar francesa
en la zona de sahel iba a ser reducida y
reemplazada por una fuerza de apoyo a
los estados concernidos como pretende
francia lograr esta pirueta sin cometer
los errores afganos
esa comparación entre organista animal y
me parece un poco inexacta o sea son dos
zonas muy distintas dos países con dos
realidades muy distintas y malía hay que
entender algo o sea cuando se dice
algunos especialistas que hablan de mari
como si fuera musulmán
no es exactamente
real o sea mal y como muchos países de
la zona son países animistas primero o
sea son países que tienen sus propias
religiones y luego son musulmanes aunque
esa realidad está cambiando poco a poco
por más o menos el islam radical que se
está imponiendo sobre las religiones
locales luego bueno francia no quiere
retirarse del sahel o sea quiere
retirarse del mal y poco a poco el mal y
es uno de los países de sawyer que es
una zona grande con los cinco o seis
siete países entre cuales moritán ya
níger burkina faso y que todos están
metidos en esa guerra contra los
diaristas pero francia +1 que de
reorganizarse entonces francia que más o
menos responsabilizar a los malienses de
su destino frente a esa amenaza
terrorista
pero no sé si coinciden con el compañero
de que no es tan comparable la retirada
de tropas estadounidenses de afganistán
con la de francia del sahel como lo ven
vea
efectivamente la situación es
completamente distinta es verdad que lo
que tenemos que hacer es aprender de los
errores que hemos cometido en afganistán
porque las operaciones mensaje el llevan
ya ocho años son son muchos años pero lo
que está claro es que la sociedad civil
y las crisis de gobernanza es que hay en
el sahel sobre todo en mali son
completamente distintas al escenario a
panistas y también sobre todo que los
grupos yihadistas son unos actores pero
de hecho tenemos aquí y tenemos los
grupos ligados ligados a da es pues que
además tenemos a la revolución tuareg
del norte de mali que bueno aunque ahora
ya se han calmado las cosas esos son
actores armados que siguen el terreno
tenemos muchas milicias
intercomunitarias entonces no es como en
el caso de afganistán donde había una
fuerza que son los talibanes y luego
estaba el estado en este caso la
presencia internacional también es
distinta en afganistán en la operación
americana en mali hay más actores está
la muy europea involucrada pero también
esta misma que es un gran actor en la
región
barkani así que los escenarios no me
parecen comparables pero lo que sí que
me parece muy interesante es aprender de
lo que ha ocurrido en afganistán para
evitar cometer los mismos errores no es
comparable para usted tampoco robben en
los escenarios los contextos son
diferentes pero obviamente yo creo que
la retirada de eeuu de afganistán tiene
un eco obviamente en el sahel porque en
los dos casos también tenemos
intervenciones militares extranjeras
occidentales y que vemos los límites y
también los límites es que tratar
solamente síntomas con ejércitos
extranjeros obviamente que eso no
responde a los causales de los problemas
de sahel y entonces
ahí también estamos en esta situación
después de ocho años de en particular de
francia militarmente involucrada en el
sahel y vemos que si nos respondemos
también a los temas de gobernanza de
desigualdad de pobreza que todo eso
alimenta fuertemente las crisis en el
sahel obviamente es un ciclo que nunca
se va a terminar qué balance podrían
hacer de estos años de presencia de
francia sahel como podríamos calibrar un
poco al principio la operación que
estaba en francia y que estaba en el
sahel de francia era observar y tenía un
objetivo claro que era parar a los
yihadistas que estaban bajando porque
las fuerzas armadas malienses se habían
retirado por causa de la revolución
tuareg y entonces estaba el norte
totalmente vacío y los grupos yihadistas
se habían cogido junto con los grupos
armados para que prácticamente toda la
región y observar si consiguió parar y
si consiguió liberar grandes ciudades
como timbuktú que pasa que el conflicto
se ha enquistado porque porque el
yihadismo ha avanzado muy rápidamente y
si el yihadismo avanza tan rápidamente
es porque los grupos yihadistas reclutan
a las comunidades más marginadas y les
venden un discurso de igualdad nosotros
sí que pensamos en vosotros y claro pues
contra esa una operación militar como
bien decía es prácticamente imposible
acabar con las mismas comunidades que
están en níger en burkina y en mali
entonces cuando un mensaje cada dentro
de una comunidad las fronteras son muy
porosas entonces claro los mensajes
avanzadas y así es efectivamente como la
expansión se ha producido el objetivo de
todas las operaciones que en la zona en
las que participa francia es luchar
contra grupos terroristas como
comentábamos no sé si podemos decir que
desde 2012 la situación ha empeorado no
se lo podremos decir así la retirada
francesa no dejará más espacio a los
yihadistas está bien que no ha empezado
empeorado eso es una visión muy parisina
y no muy del terreno cuando se conoce un
poco a mali y cuando uno como yo por
ejemplo yo estuve en el 2012 cuando
cuando después del golpe de estado
contra el presidente ex presidente
maliense amadou touré llegó algunos ya
listas que ocuparon todo el norte del
país el norte del país o sea habían
sharia todos los días justicia islámica
todos los días en estos en esto en esa
región pues era un país dentro del país
un país islamista un poco como hubo en
irak
o en una parte de siria entonces esa era
la realidad cuando francia de acuerdo
con el estado maliense decidió actuar y
decidió pues hacer guerra
y eliminar a sus diez islas del norte de
mali entonces la situación era así un
país dividido en dos países hoy día no
es exactamente la misma realidad yo creo
que si francia y todos los países de la
región no habían actuado pues mal y ser
un país ya lista islamista del norte al
sur esto sería la realidad
robyn quería puntualizar si yo creo que
no podemos sobre el mal y hay que ver la
legión en general y sahel hoy en día esa
legión de áfrica donde la violencia
aumenta lo más rápido fuck son casi 3
millones de personas desplazadas y
también lo que hay que ver el poema de
stephon enfoque sumamente militar es que
también está alimentando más violencia
está en 2020 hubo más civiles matados
por el ejército de mali que por grupos
yihadistas u otros grupos terroristas en
la región en el país entonces lo que
vemos también es que hay que volver a
poner en tome la protección de los
civiles
las estrategias militares que lleva a
cabo la comunidad internacional pero
también los ejércitos nacionales tenemos
matanzas por el ejército en níger en
burkina faso entonces esta situación es
muy grave y si está empeorando según
nosotros y no es una visión parisina
pero si está de acuerdo que aunque se ha
hecho demasiado hincapié en ese enfoque
militar como decía robin así por
supuesto porque al final es lo más
sencillo sobre todo para los
occidentales enviar tropas y enviar
dinero y dárselo al gobierno es
efectivamente lo más fácil así que estoy
totalmente de acuerdo la situación ha
empeorado ahora no creo que se pueda
hacer un nexo causal entre que la
operación marcané haya estado ahí y que
la situación haya empeorado la operación
marcan y ha tenido también victorias
militares que es importante restaurar ya
en ustedes cuántas aristas y qué
complejo es este asunto del sahel vamos
a hacer en este punto una breve pausa y
enseguida volvemos para seguir
analizando lo aquí en primera plana
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
france24 la economía día a día
liberté égalité actual y te seguimos
aquí en primera plana esta semana
poniendo el foco en el sahel esa vasta
región subsahariana que preocupa tanto a
la comunidad internacional por la
propagación del terrorismo yihadista lo
hacemos con beatriz de león como
investigadora del centro de seguridad
internacional de la universidad
francisco de vitoria robin guitar
responsable de influencia para áfrica
occidental de la organización oxfam y
françois xavier fréhel and periodista
independiente que publicó en 2017 el
libro malí más allá del yihad por
hablemos de cómo funciona el yihadismo
en el sahel de su financiación y de sus
recursos la industria de los secuestros
se han multiplicado como decíamos al
principio también usan rutas de flujos
de inmigrantes ilegales no eso es una
concepción que se suele tener porque
parece ser sobre todo cuando llegan a
europa sí que es verdad que algún hijo
de esta secuela pero lo que estamos
hablando del sahel no hay una relación
entre los migrantes que van del sahel a
europa por ahora y digo por ahora como
una precaución y los yihadistas que
suben lo que sí que hacen los grupos y
hadise estás como ahí hay un poliedro y
ahí pues el grupo criminales que los
oposicionistas con grupos armados tiene
una relación sobre todo tienen a veces
incluso vínculos familiares de vez en
cuando puede ocurrir que algún grupo
yihadista ayude o de soporte por ejemplo
de seguridad a algún convoy de trata o
algún convoy que va hacia hacia el norte
de áfrica pero normalmente no no hay una
relación directa entre los flujos
migratorios lo que pasa si las cifras
son tremendas unas 3.000 personas han
sido raptadas en lo que va de año por
grupos armados y yihadistas
prácticamente el doble que en todo 2020
son cifras que impresionan cuanto menos
si son cifras que impresionan lo que hay
ver también de impacto sobre las
poblaciones también hay en el terreno
perdón
perdón de 2006 a 2012 por ejemplo a aqmi
tubos 60 millones de euros en el
recursos gracias a dos secuestros y
aparte de los secuestros que su gran
fuente de financiación también me
gustaría resaltar la afa cat que es el
'impuesto revolucionario' que a todas
las poblaciones del sahel pues los
oposicionistas van les reclaman que les
paguen ese es impuesto para los recursos
y luego también hay mucho mucho de
contrabando entonces yo creo que esos
serían las tres formas de financiarse
obteniendo sobre todo los secuestros
como mayor fuente de financiación
volvemos en este punto con françois
salida de la periodista independiente
que publicó en 2017 mal y más allá de
lijar frases había que decir de las
otras potencias a quién beneficiará el
hecho de que francia esté menos
implicado evidentemente rusia está
interesada a tener una presencia como lo
tenía antes en la época soviética en
áfrica en muchos países porque porque
áfrica es un continente con muchas
riquezas naturales
entonces sabemos también que en mali
hay un gobierno un convenio entre el
estado ruso perdón el estado maliense y
unas milicias rusas privadas pero detrás
de las rusas privadas obviamente tampoco
metido el estado ruso o sea hay que
recordar se lo que ocurrió en siria en
siria los rusos mandaron primero unas
milicias y luego mandaron las tropas
para terminar con los diez listas
entonces evidentemente rusia-china
también llega a eso se sabe muy bien que
china es la nueva superpotencia en
áfrica mucho más que francia en todos
los países casi rusia está trabajando
que haya ya listas que haya demócratas
noreen bordes y luego hay potencias más
pequeñas pero que son muy muy
importantes y muy presente que son por
ejemplo turquía turquía que detrás de
intereses económicos
obviamente intereses religiosos y luego
también hay todos los países del golfo
si antes denunciaba robben una visión
demasiado militarista en esta cuestión
no sé si la pregunta sería entonces si
es imprescindible una respuesta militar
al terrorismo o que otras respuestas o
que otras estrategias deben ponerse en
marcha a robben bueno yo creo que hay
temas de gobernanza es que es clave y
que la comunidad internacional han
minimizado en los últimos años como
decía beatriz osa ahora mismo en el
sahel tenemos dos países que están
gobernando por la junta militar esos a
chad y malí y eso es sumamente
preocupante porque tenemos una situación
donde básicamente no hay confianza entre
poblaciones y gobernantes y entonces si
no ayudamos a reconstruir un contrato
social que está todo el interior roto en
la ciudad de sawyer obviamente vamos a
seguir sin responder otra vez a las
causales entonces hay cuestiones de
desarrollar cuestiones de gobernanza hay
cuestiones de cuestión social lo que
vemos de la estrategia de francia en los
últimos años es que francia gasta cada
año mil millones de
en intervención militar entonces ha sido
en un aumento tremendo en los últimos
ocho años su ayuda internacional es
exagero está casi flat o sea no ha
cambiado en los últimos ocho años
entonces ahí también viene el problema y
esa responsabilidad también de la
comunidad internacional decir nosotros
estamos invirtiendo de manera
desproporcionada en lo militar sin
ayudar a esos países también en las
cuestiones de desarrollo es muy
problemático el músico más allá también
lo que hemos notado nosotras no exámenes
que esos países tienen presupuestos
militares y de seguridad que están muy
en aumento significa que también porque
son países pobres que tienen presupuesto
cada vez más menos reducidos para
justamente invertir en la salud pública
en la educación en la protección social
en política agrícola porque son también
sociedades muy agrícolas y entonces hay
que invertir las dinámicas donde el
militar está llevando casi todo
y en esta cuestión de las inversiones
aparece también un elemento claro que a
mí me parece que es la juventud no está
es carencia sobre todo de una juventud
sin perspectivas no sé si pero dicen que
es un enrolamiento en los grupos
criminales en las grupos criminales por
supuesto al final es dinero fácil y
bueno pues los grupos criminales pagan
muy bien e incluso los grupos yihadistas
también los grupos armados en general
para pagar muy bien y lo más importante
en los ángeles que hay una crisis
demográfica inmensa estamos hablando de
una media de seis hijos por mujer que
tienen en níger malí en algunos sitios
de malí y en burkina faso entonces
cuando tienes tanta demografía el cambio
climático que hace que haya menos
pues menos por ejemplo porciones
agrícolas disponibles para una población
en aumento
te encuentras con una juventud que no
tiene muchas salidas muchas
oportunidades laborales y justo la
criminalidad organizada sobre todo es en
los círculos que se forman alrededor de
las ciudades grandes porque las personas
bajan de poblados que están pues por
toda la zona intentan ir a una ciudad
grande pensando que van a tener más
oportunidades y no y es ahí justo cuando
se enrolan en este tipo de bandas claves
que robinson países demográficamente muy
jóvenes y una juventud sin perspectivas
sí pero creo que el tema de la juventud
es muy muy interesante pero siendo
también un poco más optimista yo creo
que también quizás es la cabeza de
solución porque tenemos una población
efectivamente muy joven y pero que está
también aportando muchas soluciones
nosotros en lo que sanz trabajos muchos
con grupos movimientos de juventud en
esta región y lo hemos visto por ejemplo
durante la pandemia son grupos de
jóvenes movilizando sus comunidades
llevando sus luces muy concretas y
entonces no está esa juventud no está
esperando
respuestas de sus gobiernos o respuesta
de la comunidad internacional no son muy
activos desde ya y entonces yo creo que
es también ahí hay que poner más enfoque
apoyan más a esos grupos espacio a
grupos de mujeres porque también son
pues históricamente más las que están al
cien más margen iniciadas en esas
ciudades como en casi todas las ciudades
del mundo y entonces yo creo que hay
también mucho optimismo que tener con
esta juventud y entonces hay que
apoyarla más
la situación volvemos en este punto con
françois xavier frena en la situación en
la región no es para nada estable mal y
en chad golpes de estado hace pocos
meses las tensiones entre parís y
argelia son más que palpables además del
costo humano y financiero este contexto
es un argumento más para revaluar
digamos su presencia en la zona francia
en cualquier caso no quiere salir a la
res estadounidense de afganistán digamos
hay que entender que hoy francia
adquiere absolutamente que los europeos
se agrupan con con ella para también
evitar una nueva ola
en migratoria después de que por ejemplo
pues los dietistas los islamistas toman
mother en bamako por ejemplo más que
todo francia quiere salir de este desde
esa zona con la cara alta blatter como
se dice en francia o sea es evidente que
francia no va a reemplazar los estados
de esa región y no lo quiere o sea pero
tampoco quiere salir de la forma que
salió
estadounidense eeuu de afganistán o sea
yo creo que alguna media y france está
buscando pues una forma de salir
dignamente de esa zona que de todas
formas es la zona muy caótica donde no
se sabe el futuro muy bien y yo diría un
feliz y la mente dónde puede llegar
todavía los islamista al poder porque
porque al final la gente lo que quiere
es comer
vivir tranquilamente y si hay que elegir
a los islamistas van a elegir a los
pactos a los islamistas
y quieren paz y eso creo que la
diplomacia francesa lo tiene bien en
cuenta y luego un punto que por últimos
pasó un poco de refilón es el tema del
pago de rescates que aquí cada país
funciona de una forma distinta hay
varios asuntos de fondo como la cuestión
ética de cómo los estados occidentales
deben comportarse respecto a los
secuestros no les voy a preguntar lo que
se debe hacer pero sí quién debe
determinar eso porque a veces lo que
parece es que son los estados en este
punto actúan según las pulsiones de la
opinión pública no en teoría los estados
occidentales no negocian con yihadistas
en teoría en la práctica por ejemplo en
lo último que ocurrió con sophie pedro
ning y el líder de la oposición maría
pues ahí en teoría fue mal y el que hizo
ese acuerdo con los yihadistas los
malienses y las poblaciones del terreno
han acordado con ellos toda la vida
porque es que los líderes del de la
yihad en el sahel no vienen de arabia
saudí es que son nacidos y crecidos en
mali y algunos han tenido hasta cargos
políticos como el jefe de al qaeda mono
de la facción de al qaeda que está allí
entonces es muy
y tener en cuenta que los propios novios
los conocen muy bien y ellos han sido
los que han decidido negociar y en
teoría lo que pasa es que hay
consecuencias para las misiones
internacionales por eso francia se
oponen tanto a las negociaciones con
yihadistas entonces yo pienso que por
supuesto tienen que ser ellos los que
los que decidan apoyados o no por la
comunidad internacional depende depende
del país y las circunstancias bueno pues
para quedar me gustaría preguntarles a
los dos mirando al futuro qué políticas
deberían implementarse para controlar el
terrorismo en el sahel ya más brevemente
robyn una pregunta muy muy grande
obviamente yo lo que ha faltado mucho a
los 8 años que francia está ahí en la
región es que no hay debate público en
francia sobre lo que hacemos allá y cómo
lo hacemos
hubo una operación real si no no es que
no interesa es que básicamente tenemos
decisiones que están tomadas desde el
elíseo y que no hay debate público no
hay debate tampoco en el palais mental
en el parlamento en francia ya tuvimos
una operación ser var en 2013 hubo un
voto
en el congreso en francia hubo la
operación barkan después y nunca se votó
más sobre lo que nosotros hacemos allá y
cómo lo hacemos entonces
y ahora yo creo que es el momento clave
tenemos una reestructuración de barkhan
tenemos el ejemplo de algún instante
hemos elecciones que están por venir en
francia yo creo que es el momento de
abrir un debate público y sobre todo de
escuchar a la gente de sage de la
sociedad civil del sahel de las
poblaciones y de la juventud del sahel
porque son ellos que tienen la respuesta
no somos nosotros occidentales de cómo
vamos a resolver esos problemas porque
como dijo el otro intervenir ante o sea
no es franz a que va a cambiar las cosas
hay que ver cómo apoyar soluciones
concretas del terreno pues ya me quedo
sin tiempo para más muchísimas gracias
por haberme acompañado en este en esta
edición en un tema tan complejo o
beatriz de león como robyn guitar y
françois xavier frenan ha sido un placer
compartir estos minutos con ustedes
nosotros nos despedimos aquí pero
volvemos la próxima semana quien en
primera plana de radio france
internacional y de france 24 muchas
gracias
[Música]